[Música]
una serie de explosiones impactaron
kabul en zonas del centro de la ciudad
áreas que son muy pobladas y con
edificios gubernamentales hay al menos
ocho muertos y decenas de heridos hasta
ahora ningún grupo se ha atribuido la
responsabilidad del ataque escala la ira
en brásil con protestas en varias
ciudades por el asesinato de un hombre
afrodescendiente a manos de dos guardias
de seguridad en un supermercado cuyas
brutales agresiones fueron grabadas el
vicepresidente brasileño afirmó que no
existe racismo pero acepto una brutal
desigualdad fruto de una serie de
problemas
venezuela ya vive el ambiente electoral
a 15 días de los comicios legislativos
del 6 de diciembre siguen los
preparativos de las polémicas votaciones
en las que no participará el grueso de
la oposición juan guaidó instó a los
ciudadanos a rechazar las parlamentarias
que el líder opositor considera
fraudulentos analizamos con una
constructora política venezolana
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina' y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria sean bienvenidos
empezamos en afganistán y es que una
serie de explosiones dejan al menos ocho
muertos en kabul el ataque se produce
antes de una nueva reunión en doha entre
el gobierno afgano y los talibanes con
la mediación del secretario de estado de
eeuu mike pompeo y después de que esta
semana el pentágono anunciara la pronta
retirada de más de dos mil tropas
estadounidenses del país los detalles
los tienen marina sardiña
una ráfaga de morteros golpea kabul la
capital de afganistán durante la mañana
del sábado el caos se apoderó de las
calles del centro de la ciudad tras la
explosión de una docena de cohetes que
dejan al menos ocho muertos y decenas de
heridos eran aproximadamente las nueve
de la mañana cuando un mortero golpeó el
área de sartén a frente al centro
comercial màgic y la panadería slice
hiriendo a uno de los empleados quien
fue llevado al hospital el atentado ha
dejado pérdidas financieras y los
múltiples impactos provocaron cuantiosos
daños materiales en varias áreas
residenciales afganistán está asumido de
nuevo en una ola de violencia con
diferentes grupos terroristas entre los
que se encuentra una filial del estado
islámico operando en el territorio
estábamos saliendo de nuestra casa
cuando ocurrió una explosión y dos de
mis hermanas y mi madre fueron heridas
las hemos llevado al hospital a favor de
los talibanes que continúan dialogando
una parte estancada emitieron una rápida
negando cualquier responsabilidad los
insurgentes prometieron no atacar zonas
urbanas en virtud del acuerdo de
retirada de eeuu pero el portavoz del
ministerio del interior afgano ocupa el
grupo de la reciente escalada de
violencia los terroristas talibanes se
enfrentan a la nación el evento
terrorista de hoy es la enemistad
evidente de los terroristas con el
pueblo un nuevo ataque que se produce
cuando el secretario de estado de eeuu
mike pompeo se reunirá en doha con
representantes del gobierno afgano y los
talibanes en medio de las conversaciones
de paz para un país desgastado por una
guerra endémica
el último empujón de la campaña de
donald trump luego de perder una batalla
jurídica tras otra el mandatario
estadounidense se reunió este viernes en
washington con los líderes republicanos
de michigan en un intento de revertir
los resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales nos cuenta la noticia
matías a raíz
[Música]
los principales líderes legislativos
republicanos del estado de michigan
estuvieron en la casa blanca este
viernes con el presidente de donald
trump detrás de la reunión que convocó
la jefa de prensa de la presidencia
podría estar una voluntad de revertir
los resultados en el estado de los
grandes lagos hay demandas muy reales
que la campaña está llevando a cabo 234
páginas de declaraciones juradas
disponibles al público en un solo
condado es el condado de wayne y dos
individuos en el comité de escrutinio
que se han negado a certificar
después de la reunión el líder de la
mayoría del senado de michigan
mallorquín y el presidente de la cámara
de representantes
lizette fold dijeron que seguirán la ley
y el proceso normal con respecto a los
electores que eligieron al demócrata joe
biden con más de 150.000 votos a favor
de ninguna legislatura estatal en la
historia de nuestro país ha hecho lo que
donald trump aparentemente agita para
que la legislatura estatal de michigan
haga que es ignorar los resultados
una elección de voto popular y arrebatar
el control a los votantes o intentarlo y
nombrar a su propia lista de electores
para enviar a washington washington las
opciones de triunfo para donald trump se
estrechan con esta otra derrota en
pensilvania el candidato pide que la
elección sea totalmente descartada por
un posible fraude cada estado tiene
hasta el día 8 de diciembre para
resolver todas las disputas y certificar
sus resultados 16 días antes del
resultado definitivo del colegio
electoral programado para el 14 de
diciembre
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en brásil varias ciudades fueron
escenarios de protestas contra el
racismo tras el brutal asesinato de un
hombre afrodescendiente a manos de dos
guardias de seguridad tiene un
supermercado de portoalegre
las viudas negras importan también en
brasil bajo ese lema cientos de personas
se movilizaron en portoalegre para
repudiar el asesinato de hecho alberto
silveira freitas un hombre negro que
murió tras recibir una paliza de dos
vigilantes en un supermercado de la red
carrefour
las protestas se replicaron en otras
ciudades del país justo en el día de la
conciencia negra que marca la lucha por
los derechos de los afrodescendientes en
brasil en río los manifestantes
ingresaron en una sucursal de la firma
francesa para repudiar los hechos y ser
negro en brásil significa que te roban
tu humanidad te roban todos tus derechos
no tienes la oportunidad de ir y venir
en paz tienes el sistema de seguridad
diseñado para tenerte como acusado
incluso cuando eres la víctima en sao
paulo una movilización partido desde el
museo de la ciudad hasta las afueras de
otro local del supermercado para
denunciar lo que califican de racismo
estructural en el país
lo que vimos en portoalegre es la
expresión más despreciable del racismo
estructural del racismo institucional y
de cuanto se mantiene en brásil la
herencia de los paises esclavizadores
que actuaron en las américas
las protestas mayormente pacíficas
terminaron con algunos destrozos en sao
paulo los manifestantes también
rechazaron las políticas del gobierno de
saiz bolsonaro su vicepresidente de
hamilton morado desestimó que la muerte
de joao alberto sea un episodio de
discriminación racial y aseguró que en
brasil no existe racismo
los preparativos de cara a los comicios
legislativos del 6 de diciembre
continúan en venezuela en medio del
rechazo de la oposición de la
intensificación del debate electoral
entre las principales fuerzas políticas
efe un llamado del opositor juan guaidó
a una consulta popular organizada por
los detractores del gobierno de nicolás
maduro en la que preguntarán a la
ciudadanía si rechaza estas
parlamentarias es por ello que enlazamos
con la profesora carmen beatriz
fernández consultora política venezolana
muchas gracias profesora por esta
comunicación porque rechaza el grueso de
los opositores los comicios legislativos
del 6 de diciembre el no participar en
estas votaciones es la edición correcta
para la oposición
la oposición rechaza más que la posición
las fuerzas democráticas de la sociedad
que son incluso más más amplias que la
propia oposición rechazan de plano de
esta convocatoria al 6 de diciembre
porque se trata de una convocatoria que
es por un lado ilegal porque viola la
ley electoral que impide hacer cambios a
la norma en los seis meses que preceden
a una elección pero esta y ésta se
hicieron unos cambios muy profundos
antes de ese periodo pero aún más grave
que esto es es una convocatoria
inconstitucional pues dibuja un
parlamento que es distinto al que
expresa la constitución y unas reglas de
elección y de representación distintas a
las expresadas por la constitución pero
además de eso es propia el derecho al
voto directo de las poblaciones
indígenas que es muy grave y confisca
además el derecho a voto y a la
representación política de los 5
millones de venezolanos que son aunque
están en el exilio y son
de esa amplísima diáspora que está por
todo el mundo que no no están teniendo
derecho a votar en este proceso
profesora de esta consulta que promueve
juan guaidó y la oposición preguntará a
los venezolanos si rechazan estas
parlamentarias también solicita a la
comunidad internacional su
desconocimiento cómo deben responder los
actores internacionales y puede tener
algún peso esta consulta opositora nos
quedan sólo unos 45 segundos
bueno rapidísimo es una consulta que
evidentemente no sustituye en ningún
proceso electoral porque cualquier
proceso electoral debe ser basado en un
amplio consenso eso es lo que define un
proceso electoral más que más que la
elección en sí es que la base sea
producto de un consenso eso no lo cubre
ni ni la elección ni esta convocatoria
al 66 pero tampoco lamentablemente la
consulta que simplemente una muestra de
descontento ante lo que se considera una
convocatoria ilegal e inconstitucional
muchas gracias profesora por sus
comentarios por su brevedad y por su
entendimiento a la profesora carmen
beatriz fernández consultora política
venezolana y nos vamos a otro país y es
que el vicepresidente de guatemala
guillermo castillo le pidió este viernes
al mandatario alejandro giammatei que
ambos presentarán su carta de renuncia
castillo aseguró que le planteó también
al presidente vetar el decreto del
presupuesto 2021 el mayor en la historia
del país que genera endeudamiento y
rechazo de los water
vamos a este informe de aurora abajo no
ha sido por el bien del país con esa
fórmula el vicepresidente de guatemala
pidió al presidente que renuncien juntos
asimismo admitió que no tiene una buena
relación con el mandatario y quien no
comparte muchos asuntos que forman parte
de la agenda del estado quiero dejar muy
claro el planteamiento que le he hecho
al presidente por el bien del país que
presentemos ambos nuestra renuncia al
cargo el presidente y yo de
vicepresidente de la república pero que
lo hagamos juntos la declaración de
castellón se desató luego de una oleada
de protestas en redes sociales en contra
de la aprobación del presupuesto del
estado 2021 avalado por el presidente
alejandro giammatei el pasado miércoles
este presupuesto es criticado por sumar
endeudamiento y por haber sido aprobado
sin discusión en el congreso
casio también ha solicitado al
presidente que evalúen juntos las
carteras del estado para remover a
varios ministros minutos antes de que
castillo planteara la propuesta de
disolución del actual gobierno ya mate
ya había expresado su intención de
mantener vigente al presupuesto aprobado
debo aclarar que me sentaré con todos
los que sea necesario para explicarles
paso a paso el presupuesto 2021 y
aclarar dudas porque jamás en la
historia se ha presentado un presupuesto
menor al año anterior a diversos grupos
de la sociedad han convocado a una
manifestación este sábado para mostrar
su descontento a la aprobación opaca de
un presupuesto que según especialistas
prioriza la asignación a
infraestructuras pero descuida a la
población y sus necesidades miles de
etíopes han cruzado la frontera con
ciudadana en poco más de una semana para
escapar del conflicto que enfrenta al
ejército de etiopía con las fuerzas del
frente popular de liberación de tigray
en la región del mismo nombre quienes
huyen lo hacen sin nada para encontrarse
en condiciones extremas y sin la ayuda
que necesitan la 1 advierte que sudan ya
está desbordado y que se necesitan unos
200 millones de dólares para responder a
sus
y mire para finalizar cambiado la página
y es que con el segundo bloqueo en
francia en el país sólo se permite la
venta de artículos esenciales pero con
la navidad a la vuelta de la esquina el
gobierno agregó recientemente los
árboles navideños a esta lista
podría considerarse un milagro navideño
algo de alegría festiva está surgiendo
en las ciudades de francia mientras se
alzan los árboles de navidad en las
calles y en los centros comerciales
[Música]
conocido por su mercado navideño
cancelado este año estrasburgo le dio la
bienvenida a su icónico gran es zapping
como todos los años es precioso no puedo
esperar para verlo iluminado con las
restricciones sólo se permiten los
artículos esenciales la semana pasada el
gobierno agregó los árboles de navidad
aunque todavía está cerrada la
floristería puede vender árboles al aire
libre
sería triste una navidad sin un árbol
sin regalos sin celebraciones sin
diversión para los niños por eso los
árboles constituyen una gran parte de
los ingresos anuales de los floristas y
una gran parte de nuestro negocio y la
capacidad de vender estos árboles cara a
cara cambian las cosas por los
productores de árboles de navidad se
pusieron en marcha la mayoría proviene
del parque natural los fans y la navidad
puede representar más de una cuarta
parte de sus ventas anuales dibujado hoy
cortaremos unos 700 750 árboles fac para
la mayoría de los productores la
autorización a la venta de árboles llegó
justo a tiempo por suerte lo supimos
porque después del 20 de noviembre
habría sido demasiado tarde no
hubiéramos tenido tiempo de cortar los
árboles ni entregarlos hay mucho trabajo
por delante el año pasado los franceses
compraron casi 6 millones de árboles
muchas gracias y ya con más en france 24
[Música]